bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre
édition du 12 13 en normandie en direct
du village des jeux équestres mondiaux
nous avons installé nos notre studio
toute cette semaine nous sommes au sein
de l'événement mondial de l'équitation
quinze jours de compétition qui se
poursuivent ce mercredi avec en ce
moment même au stade dans l'anneau le
grand prix spécial de dressage deux
cavaliers français étaient attendus dans
la carrière ce matin on en parle dans un
instant l'événement de la fin de semaine
sur ces jeux ce sera aussi le début du
concours complet dans l'orne au haras du
pin cinquante mille personnes sont
attendues
les délégations sont déjà arrivés depuis
quelques jours et pour les accueillir le
lieu a dû véritablement se métamorphoser
le reportage d'adèle de celle-ci et de
damien mignot au coeur du site classé du
haras du pin des rangées de containers
160 chambres deux étoiles
tous les cavaliers des fédérations sont
logés là avec les vétérinaires les chefs
d'equipe donc c'est l'hébergement
temporaire qui est là et paix qui repart
dans une semaine et des chambres tout
confort avec climatisation télévision et
internet
douches toilettes et trois lits c'est
super c'est très proche avec les chevals
et c'est super c'est très pratique
en plus des cavaliers des vétérinaires
et des chefs d'equipe il a aussi fallu
trouver une solution pour loger tous
ceux qui s'occupent des chevaux au plus
près des écuries c'est une chambre pour
les groupes donc il ya deux lits ce sont
des contenaires pliable contrairement à
ceux pour les cavaliers
en plus de tous ces hôtels temporaire il
ya aussi ces camions qui nous servira à
mener les chevaux et dans lesquelles
vivent certains membres des délégations
vit bien ici très bien cochettes séjour
cuisine parfaitement bien installé comme
dans sa banque une carte pour les jeux
équestres le haras du pin a dû se
métamorphoser en tout près de 300
personnes y sont logés et pendant les
compétitions des centaines de bénévoles
et jusqu'à 50000 spectateurs se rendront
sur le site
c'est un organisation monumentale que
quand on n'est pas dedans on peut pas
imaginer le boulot qui pourrait avoir
pour que tout marche comme il faut on a
prévu un planning en amont on a commencé
à installer le 1er août
donc on a réussi à monter ça dans un
temps record
donc tout tout bien tout est prêt pour
accueillir dès demain une des épreuves
les plus importantes de ces jeux le
concours complet
anthony masto bonjour vous suivez pour
nous la compétition de ces jeux
équestres les premiers podiums des jeux
se sont déroulés hier avec en reining le
sacre attendu des américains mais les
américains qui décidément et roanne sont
indétrônables après jerez en 2002 après
aix la chapelle en 2006 après lexington
en 2010 ils ont décroché hier leur
quatrième titre de champion du monde par
équipes ils étaient les grands favoris
n'ont pas failli ils ont même offert du
grand spectacle sur la deuxième marche
du podium on retrouve la belgique la
médaille de bronze elle revient à
l'autriche quant à la france est bien
elle ne termine que 10e et ce malgré
quelques très belles prestations et
notamment celle d'anne sophie guiraud un
peu déçu les français qui visait une
sixième place
trois cavaliers français y participeront
quand même à la consolante de la finale
en individuel avant de parler par
adressage on part tout de suite au stade
d'ornano se poursuit en ce moment même
la compétition de dressage avec le grand
prix spécial individuel où vous vous
trouvez au stade d'ornano corinne de
rosa bonjour on attendait ce matin deux
cavaliers français
oui et je suis avec arnaud serre qui
vient de passer à l'instant arnaud il ya
de très très belles choses avec votre
cheval lusitanien
et puis quelques petits soucis sur les
changements de pied oui oui
le cheval est jeune c'est un jeune
cheval tchèque 9 ans l'objectif était de
faire le grand prix pas de faire grand
prix spécial
donc il est passé mardi dont un tiers
donc on n'a pas eu le temps de
retravailler le grand prix spécial donc
c'est un peu un péché de jeunesse du
cheval un peu de fatigue aussi
donc j'ai quelques fautes sur l'énigme
est bon c'est fatigant n'attendiez pas
vous retrouver ici aujourd'hui c'était
par l'objectif prioritaire l'objectif
prioritaire c'était d'être le mieux
possible pour l'équipe et ensuite on
espérait quand même faire partie du
spécial mais on savait que ce serait
difficile
vous avez un parcours très atypique vous
avez commencé par le horse ball fab vous
avez monté par le dressage vous êtes
revenu horse ball vous avez
monter voilà vous êtes vous vous êtes
monté l'ont longtemps en ce bol ça vous
fait quoi d'être ici en dressage c'est
une fierté après c'est mon travail 1
depuis toujours je reste des chevaux je
faisais du horse ball pour m'amuser donc
c'est beaucoup de travail beaucoup de
patience c'est difficile donc je prépare
le choix depuis deux ans pour cette
échéance
donc c'est c'est bien on est content
merci merci
et puis voilà et puis le para dressage
se poursuit également anthony oui après
deux jours de compétition les épreuves
de parra dressage se poursuivent et
effectivement ce matin alors c'est un
peu plus difficile de s'y retrouver en
par adressage car il ya plusieurs
niveaux de compétition suivant les
handicaps
ça fonctionne par grade en grade 3 une
reprise un peu moins bonne que celle du
premier tour pour samuel katell sur
mogador de volanges ce matin sur ces
images on suivra de près le classement
de la france qui pour l'instant est tout
à fait honorable et roanne merci anthony
demain la grande épreuve dès 7 heures du
matin ce sera l'endurance un marathon de
160 km dans la baie du mont saint michel
et l'on s'arrête ce midi sur cette
discipline de l'endurance une épreuve
dans laquelle il faut aller vite mais
aussi surveiller le coeur de son cheval
présentation axée reportage signé donc
anthony masto et patrick soulabaille
20 40 90 et jusqu'à 160km de nombreuses
épreuves d'endurance sont organisées
partout en france chaque week-end et
notamment dans l'ouest
ce jour là nous avons rendez-vous à
tonquédec au coeur de la bretagne
nous y retrouvons valérie et son cheval
ouzou de kerdavid un pur sang arabe de 9
ans ils vont partir pour 40 km en fait
il faut qu'on se qualifie pour atteindre
des courses de 90 ou 120 donc là les
courses de 20 40 60 c'est tranquille
qu'enfin tout cas nous on le vit comme
ça
par contre après oui quand on atteint
des courses de 90 km vitesse libre où là
c'est le premier qui arrive qu'à gagner
ben là c'est c'est la compétition et
tandis que valérie prend le départ
jacques son compagnon lui prend la route
il doit retrouver valérie tous les 5 km
en moyenne et ce n'est pas si simple
c'est là à gauche contre castres
l'endurance équestre est un travail
d'équipé dans sa camionnette
jacques fait suivre la logistique à
chaque point de rencontre il faut
refroidir le cheval et éventuellement le
faire boire car la cadence et soutenu il
y à un rythme à respecter d'ailleurs
jacques s'inquiètent de ne pas voir
arriver valérie il faut faire entre
minimum 12 km heure au maximum 15 km
heure pour être classé disons que sur
ces courses là
beaucoup de gens viennent pour assurer
la qualification est donc prennent pas
de risques c'est pour ça qu'aujourd'hui
j'ai l'impression que ça va pas vite du
tout quoi il fait frais d'ouzoud est en
forme
valérie prend à peine le temps de
s'arrêter
comme les autres concurrents elle doit
maintenant terminée rapidement sa
première boucle
valérie ouzoud aval finalement ses 20
premiers kilomètres en un peu moins
d'une heure et demie j'ai du relief et
il n'a pas plu mais c'est assez humide
donc battu faire attention donc j'allais
un peu de retard au début et après quand
j'ai pu galoper la bâche et j'essaie de
récupérer mon retard parce que j'avance
est vraiment pas vite soit valérie doit
maintenant attendre une heure avant de
repartir dès que le rythme cardiaque de
son cheval sera redescendue elle ira le
présenter au vétérinaire comme le veut
le règlement notre rôle c'est d'être sûr
que le cheval peut repartir sur la
prochaine et donc la fréquence cardiaque
que ce soit normal dira que ça devait
être inférieur à 64 que le transit
également ce normal et sur tout le
cheval soit pop boiteux un bon cheval
d'endurance est un cheval dont le coeur
ne bat pas trop vite c'est l'une des
qualités des pur sang arabe une race que
l'on trouve dans quelques élevages
bretons très réputé de grandes fortunes
des émirats passionnés d'endurance
viennent chercher leurs chevaux
disciplines évoluent d'abord elle est
assez mondialisée avec eux des pays qui
sont acheteurs de chevaux si fait que ça
a fait développer l'élevage et ça a fait
une recherche de dans la génétique et
d'un la morphologie des chevaux qui
permettent d'aller plus loin plus vite
retour dans la course à peine le temps
de regarder le décor médiéval valérie
doit maintenir le rythme m l'épreuve se
terminera finalement sans encombre notre
cavalière et son cheval décrochent leur
qualification pour des épreuves de
niveau supérieur
antonio on compare souvent cette épreuve
un marathon de course à pied en fait
ouais ouais non marathon à ceci près
qu'il y à quatre phases de récupération
pendant cette course une course qui fait
quand même 160 km 1 demain près de neuf
heures à cheval dans un cadre magnifique
qu'est la baie du mont saint michel
deux cent soixante cavaliers sont
engagés
cinq français et notamment un voisin
breton denis le guillou il faut dire que
la bretagne est la région qui compte le
plus grand nombre de licenciés en
endurance et l'histoire de denis le
guillou est assez intéressante car il
est amateur dans la vraie vie il est en
fait dirigeant d'une pme ils concourent
sur authie minsart mort j'espère que
j'ai corrige pas le nom de son cheval un
petit anglo-arabe de 12 ans et on suivra
de près tous les cavaliers français car
il ya peut-être là des espoirs de
médaille même si en individuel ce sont
les émirats arabes le qatar et l'espagne
qui vont jouer le tout pour le tout ils
seront également surveillées de près car
on sait que dans cette discipline
l'endurance il ya eu quelques dérapages
et notamment en ce qui concerne le
dopage on aura l'occasion d'y revenir et
roanne et on l'a dit autour de sarti les
cavaliers se mesureront dans le cadre
majestueux de la baie du mont saint
michel à un très beau spectacle en
perspective
plus de 5000 spectateurs sont attendus
tous les billets ont été vendus mais il
reste encore une possibilité d'assister
à la compétition nomme sans billet infos
pratiques avec stéphanie vino et jouer
la mare l'endurance c'est un circuit de
160 kilomètres répartis en cinq parcours
pour les gens qui ont acheté un billet
il est conseillé d'arriver sur le site
de sortie dès 6 heures du matin pour
assister au départ vers 7 heures sans
billets il suffit de se positionner sur
le bord de la route
cet endroit avec des parkings ont été
tout spécialement préparé pour
accueillir le public
on a imaginé trois dispositifs pour les
spectateurs qui peuvent se rendre sur
les plages de jullouville de kairon de
carole de dragey afin d'aller voir la
course à des heures bien précises
puisque les heures de passage ont été
communiqués et pour avoir les détails
des boucles et des horaires de passage
il suffit de se rendre sur le site
internet des jeux équestres mondiaux en
voiture le circuit est libre d'accès la
seule contrainte de circulation ce jour
là sera l'acte granville avranches qui
sera coupé de 7h à 10h au niveau de
saint pierre langers la première boucle
empruntés par les concurrents sectionne
garde 1973 au niveau de la commune de
saint pierre langers donc là on est
obligé d'interrompre totalement la
circulation dans les deux sens pendant
le passage des chevaux qui s'effectue en
deux phases une phase aller une phase
retour
il est donc conseillé aux automobilistes
qui ferait avranches granville ou
inversement de passer par la haye-pesnel
pour éviter le secteur en direct
toujours des jeux équestres mondiaux on
continue de jongler entre les
disciplines et on retourne au stade
d'ornano où se poursuivent les épreuves
et là le grand prix spécial individuel
de dressage corinne kérosène il y avait
deux français
ce matin on a entendu tout à l'heure
arnaud serre il y avait également marc
boblet oui marc goblet qui n'était pas
prévu dans cette finale aujourd'hui et
qui a été repêché in extremis hier soir
donc il a fait une bonne prestation ce
matin avec sa très belle jument nobel
dream il est pour l'instant dans les dix
premiers du classement provisoire mais
les meilleurs sont à passer
donc il faudra attendre la fin de la
journée pour voir si marc boblet fera
partie des 15 meilleurs ceux qui auront
droit à disputer la reprise libre en
musique
merci corinne on va maintenant faire un
tour dans les allées du village des jeux
dans lequel nous sommes installés toute
cette semaine on va retrouver au raid
misery bonjour aurélie vous allez nous
faire découvrir un sport équestre très
peu connu et bonjour et roanne il s'agit
du polo crosse alors un sport
effectivement méconnu et pourtant
l'équipe de france a un joli palmarès
elle a remporté la coupe du monde en
2011 et le challenge européen en 2008
pour nous expliquer les règles de ce
sport australien qui se pratique
essentiellement dans les pays du
commonwealth
je vais rejoindre barbarin beaufils
coach de l'équipe de france d'ailleurs
barbara se trouve devant une partie de
l'équipe de france bonjour barbara tout
d'abord il faut pas confondre le polo et
le polo croissant est tout à fait en
fait le polo cross a été créée dans les
années 1930 en australie pour
démocratiser le polo on s'est un peu le
sport des fermiers australien
et ça se joue avec une raquette donc
complètement différente d'une maille et
de polo et une balle en caoutchouc avec
des passes aériennes et la particularité
c'est qu'on a un cavalier un cheval sur
un terrain qui fait à peu près la taille
d'un terrain de foot 1 alors qu'un
terrain de polo fait quatre terrains de
foot avec une grosse cavalerie alors
dans chaque équipe
trois cavaliers mais un seul marc oui
alors la particularité c'est que chacun
un rôle sur le terrain
le numéro un c'est le buteur le numéro 2
c'est le joueur central et les numéros 3
c'est le défenseur c'est un sport qui
fait aussi la part belle à la parité 1
puisque l'équipe de france et est mixte
vous vous êtes là pour promouvoir ce
sport qui n'est pas une discipline des
jeux équestres mondiaux trop peu de
licenciés alors en france il ya très peu
de licenciés ont démarré en 2007 on a
commencé en 2007 on a à peu près 300
joueurs douzaine de clubs cependant en
australie on a plus de 8000 joueurs donc
c'est un sport qui est quand même
populaire dans une bonne partie du monde
et on espère qu'ils aient pas se
développer
démonstration cette fois de polo je vous
le rappelle samedi 6 septembre c'est à
deauville
merci aurélie ces jeux sont aussi
l'occasion de s'intéresser à la filière
cheval de nombreux métiers tourne
qu'autour de l'équitation notamment en
normandie
parmi eux dans le domaine de la santé
une spécialité rassel d'ostéopathe et
qu'un découverte avec ce reportage
d'emilie flahaut et franck boudreau
cette affiche est un indice pour les
passions de geoffroy blanchot s'ils
consultent rarement l'après midi c'est
parce qu'il se consacre à d'autres
patients beaucoup plus imposant mais
beaucoup moins bavard ok tu fais demi
tour
on commençait toujours aux séances comme
ça toujours toujours toujours pour voir
comment le cheval se mobilisent
justo pas voir comment les langages voir
comment il utilise sa ligne de dos si on
a des symétries ou des asymétries au
niveau de postérieur de la croupe des
épaules dans son ensemble pour avoir une
vision d'ensemble de la mécanique une
mécanique qui n'est d'ailleurs pas très
éloignée de celle des hommes
mais comme il leur manque la parole
l'ostéopathe et qu'un utilisent les
réflexes musculaire naturel du cheval
pour comprendre d'où viennent ces
douleurs ça c'est un réflexe plus ou
moins neutre ' chez certains shows de
même que celui ci est en fait c'est ce
qui nous permet à nous de pouvoir tester
le rascisme n'ont pratiquement dans son
ensemble rachète dorsale lambert sans
avoir à forcer forcé comme un âne et
après c'est l'éducation de la main qui
va dire si le chevalier plus ou moins
douloureux et surtout si on a un blocage
comme ici sur une charnière dorso
lombaire et il n'y en ait du travail sur
pelote qui se laisse faire sans broncher
car elle sent que je ferais blanchot lui
fait du bien
on ne demande pas plus que ce qu'il ne
pourrait pas faire juste de venir elle
va venir tout seul et là où s'affiche un
petit peu en beauce il ya une perte de
mobilité articulaire venir chercher un
axe je manipulais pour libérer
l'articulation pour être cités au pathé
qu'un il faut savoir monter à cheval
pour connaître les sensations
il faut accepter aussi que la profession
ne soit pas encore reconnu le cadre
légal d'exercice est encore floue alors
mieux vaut avoir la double casquette
qu'est ce qui est plus simple les
humains à cheval anxieux beaucoup plus
facilement gérable qu'une personne
anxieuse
parce qu'une personne anxieuse en ligne
se laissait aller va pas se laisser
aller un cheval anxieux on lui montre
qu'on n'est pas dangereux pour lui il va
se laisser aller et c'est ce que fait
pelote qui est prête pour une petite
sieste
nelson monfort
bonjour les téléspectateurs de france 3
auront le plaisir de vous retrouver pour
une heure de direct cet après midi aux
alentours de 15 heures
c'est exact sur france 3 national depuis
avant-hier nous nous sommes présents en
compagnie de christian choupin et
virginie couperie puis sur cet après
midi nous allons nous intéresser en
direct à la phase ultime du rafale à
face presque ultime du dressage qui
voudrait ensuite qualification pour les
15 meilleurs en musique ça ce sera pour
ce week-end enfin nous sommes très très
heureux d'être ici et d'être jaloux
d'être ici en votre compagnie merci
d'être sur ce plateau également le 12/13
s'achève pour ce qui ce concerne la
partie régionale il se poursuit avec la
météo plus votre édition nationale ce
soir vous retrouvez en basse-normandie
un 19/20 présenté en direct de ces jeux
équestres internet les jeux équestres
continue également sur le web avec notre
site internet bastille rennes en ont 10
points france 3 points et faire très
bonne journée à tous et à demain